mes chers collègues à l'occasion de la
loi de finances notre commission examine
les crédits de la mission
interministérielle de lutte contre les
drogues et les conduites addictives
comme on dit la 1000 des cas sur le
rapport de notre collègue brigitte
micouleau ce qui nous donne l'occasion
de faire le point sur les addictions et
la stratégie déployée par les pouvoirs
publics dans ce domaine
notre commission a également des travaux
en cours dont les rapporteurs sont jean
seul et victoire jasmin sur la santé
mentale dans le contexte de la crise
sanitaire où la question des addictions
évidemment présentes
nous entendons donc ce matin monsieur
julien morel d'arleux directoire de
l'observatoire français des drogues et
des toxicomanies l'eau fdt et le docteur
jean michel delisle et en visio à
distance que le apercevront sur l'écran
mais psychiatre et président de la
fédération addiction sur la prise en
charge des addictions
j'indique ce que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site du
sénat est disponible en vidéo à la
demande
notre objectif de ce matin est double
faire le point sur l'état des
consommations volume en tendance mais
hawks aussi examiner la stratégie qui
peut varier bien sûr en fonction des
publics des substances nous avons bien
sûr tous en tête les événements récents
du quartier stalingrad à paris et les
ravages du crack au sein de certaines
populations
comment y faire face et comment
accompagner ces personnes c'est aussi
une question que nous posons ce matin
donc suède donner la parole d'abord
monsieur morel d'arleux et au docteur de
lille pour un propos liminaire avant que
le débat ne s'engage avec les
commissaires et en priorité zone ray la
parole bien évidemment me signer
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs ta plaisir d'être devant vous
avec jean michel de lille avec qui nous
travaillons régulièrement me s'il lui
était aidé à distance en propos
introductif donc pour l'observatoire
français des drogues et des toxicomanies
cheveux n'est pas de nouveaux chiffres à
vous donner mais par contre il me
semblait important par rapport aux
travaux de notre commission et est ce
que vous venez d'évoquer madame à
présent de faire 2 2 points le premier
qui va un point de mise en perspective
puisque vous le savez sans doute
l'observatoire français des drogues et
toxicomanies a été créé et en 93 et
fonctionne depuis 1996 donc nous sommes
dans notre 25e année de fonctionnement
ce qui donne en fait une certaine mise
en perspective des données que l'on a
sur la question des addictions en france
sachant que ces travaux sont aussi je le
dis de manière spécifique aujourd'hui le
puits sicard 11 heures l'observatoire
européen des drogues et toxicomanies
donc le lit m6 didier l' agence
européenne des drogues rend son rapport
public sur l'état des drogues au niveau
de l'union européenne et donc on
participe à ce réseau depuis 25 ans donc
le réseau européen d'information sur les
drogues et toxicomanies le red sox donc
c'est d'un élément doublement
intéressante pour votre mission puisque
nous avons à la fois du recul d'un quart
de siècle sur les consommations notre
pays mais aussi pour les drogues
illicites ne pouvons les mettre en
perspective avec ce qui se passe dans
les autres pays européens
le deuxième élément d'introduction c'est
que nous vivons comme vous l'avez
rappelé comme le port du masque ou la
visioconférence le monde que nous
vivions dans un monde qui
particulièrement impactée depuis plus de
plus d'un an par une crise sanitaire
cette crise sanitaire a des effets sur
l'état de santé physique et mentale des
de nos concitoyens nous mêmes aussi
d'ailleurs par la même occasion et que
cela n'impacte pas d'addiction
sachant que pour nous à l'heure d'été on
mesure de deux points on a d'abord
pris en considération ce qui s'est passé
il ya pile un an au moment du premier
confinement qui était un confinement
strict avec une vraie mise à l'arrêt de
notre de notre société on a publié
effectivement à la rentrée de 2020 un
nouveau temps dans sa synthèse sur ce
qui s'était passé durant ce confinement
qui était une expérience inédite nomme
dans notre pays
et puis depuis un an nous nous avons
appris à vivre avec cette situation qui
est particulière mais qui nous permet
quand même de continuer à les travailler
principalement pour beaucoup de nos
concitoyens en télétravail d'avoir une
vie sociale certes contrôler les plus
limités qu'avant mais qui est en tout
cas plus plus réel que pendant le
premier confinement et donc on est dans
un deuxième temps qui a des effets sur
qui va avoir des effets sur le moyen et
sur le long terme sans doute chose sur
nos modes de vie et sur nos
consommations nos usages et donc on ne
peut pas mesurer de la même manière ce
qui a pu se passer il ya un an où on
avait effectivement un instant qu'ils
étaient données fixes et très très cadré
dans le temps et est finalement un temps
long aujourd'hui qui s'engagent et qu'il
veut dont il faudra mesurer les effets
dans plusieurs années donc comme je le
disais en introduction je n'ai pas de
nouveaux chiffres à vous donner par
rapport à ce que vous vous connaissez je
préfère un précieux point de méthodes
sûres c'est sur cette question de mesure
des addictions c'est que on est
finalement dans une situation où
aujourd'hui par le biais de la
technologie on peut assez facilement
obtenir des chiffres par des instituts
de sondage c'est ça notre enquête qui
sont menées mais ces enquêtes finalement
john d comme des coups de sonde et état
des lieux bonne pâte mesurer des
comparaisons avec ce qui s'est passé
dans les années précédentes
parce que les méthodes de collecte de
ces informations
les vedettes de sondages qu'elle ne sont
pas les mêmes et donc ne permettent pas
de comparer de manière stricte ce qui ce
qu'on avait pu collecter des années
précédentes et élise et qu'on a
aujourd'hui
à ce titre d'ailleurs même santé
publique france agence nationale de
santé publique qui mène chaque année son
baromètre santé et qu' une des partie
des éléments que nous je vous commenter
sur les les données de consommation chez
les adultes
le baromètre santé 2010 main était
comme le reste de notre société impacté
par par la crise que nous connaissons et
donc les données qui ont été collectés
la méthode de collecte de cette enquête
qui interroge plus de 2000 personnes par
téléphone chaque année a été impactée
donc les données collectées en 2020 ne
permet pas une comparaison stricte et
complète exhaustive des données avec ce
qu'on a les années précédentes
ça c'est un point la structure donc très
rapidement sur les évolutions depuis 25
ans je voulais aborder puisque j'avais
déjà eu l'occasion dans d'autres
commissions de présenter donc cette
brochure drogue chiffres-clés je vois
que certains de vos membres ont
précieusement donc j'espère que je
n'aurais pas le droit à un quizz juste
après mais donc qui rappelle les grandes
tendances et est aussi le niveau d'
usage dans notre pays en termes
d'évolution genou compter un graphique
qui qui a été repris dans cette revue
psychotropes sûr qu'elle dédie donc aux
25 ans de l'observatoire français des
drogues et des toxicomanies qui vient
d'être publiée sur lequel nous avons
fait un focus sur les évolutions donc
des 25 dernières années comme une
indication sur les évolutions des
consommations rationnellement donc des
tabac l'alcool et le cannabis avec sans
rentrer dans le détail des chiffres
pourrait il revenir totalement dans la
discussion
trois tendances qui nous paraissent
importantes de souligner parce que aussi
dans cette période de crise c'est aussi
important
le premier sur sur l'alcool puisque je
vais commencer par les produits qui sont
les plus consommés sur l'alcool on a un
élément qui méritent d'être appelés
parce que ces cartes et des changements
de consommation de se produire en france
entre le début des années 90 et
aujourd'hui on a divisé par deux et demi
le niveau de consommation d'alcool
quotidien n'en payant est passé de 24 %
des adultes qui consommaient
quotidiennement de l'alcool à 11%
aujourd'hui 10 ou 11 % c en est
maintenant depuis une dizaine d'années
sur autoroutes autour de 10% donc un
adulte sur dix qui concerne que tino en
alcool c'est un changement de
comportement générationnel puisque le
les niveaux de consommation sont plus
élevés chez
personnels les plus âgés au niveau
quotidien ce changement de consommation
il s'est aussi lié à des niveaux de
consommation régulier qui reste
important puisque pour l'alcool on n'a
pas d'eau on a pas du tout le même
changement le niveau donc d' usage dans
l'année par exemple d'alcool il reste
aux alentours de 87% donc à huit adultes
sur dix qui consomment chaque année de
l'alcool et 40% un adulte sur quatre qui
consomment tous les mois de manière donc
très très régulière donc ça c'est
premier changement sur l'alcool un
changement de mode de consommation mais
des niveaux de consommation qui reste
important et le le récent rapport de l'
expertise collective de l'inserm qui a
été remis la semaine dernière à rappeler
que toute consommation d'alcool comporte
des risques et que les les conséquences
donc en matière de santé d code de la
consommation régulière d'alcool et de
consommation d'alcool notre pays reste
reste importante
le deuxième élément on a beaucoup
commenté la semaine dernière puisque
c'était la journée mondiale de tabac
c'est les effets donc des politiques
menées depuis 30 ans pour lutter contre
le tabagisme ont offert français des
drogues et toxicomanies sorti la semaine
dernière effectivement un numéro de
bilan de ses 30 ans d'application
progressive et coordonnée de la sur son
volet sur le tabagisme avec des effets
qui ont été particulièrement marquant
marqué pendant ces dix dernières années
on va dire cinq dernières années
principalement avec les labels ce qu'on
a vu avec une politique qui l'a été à
marx et ses effets parce qu'elle est de
manière pensez manière globale
c'est-à-dire à la fois sur le prix sur
la lutte contre le marketing avec le
paquet neutre sur l'accès au traitement
avec l'accès aux traitements de
substitution nicotinique de manière
généralisée non plus forfaitisée et avec
une politique d'interdiction de
consommation aussi forte qui marquait la
fin des années 2000 par l'interdiction
de fumer dans les cafés des restaurants
l'interdiction de vente aux mineurs de
18 ans et on voit à double titre
et chez les adultes et surtout chez les
ch et des mineurs avec notre enquête
escapad à 17 ans qui a une baisse forte
de l'accès au tabagisme même si le
niveau de consommation puisque on aide
un tour de 1 français sur sur quatre qui
continua bulls qui continuent à fumer
quotidiennement du tabac on irait sur
des niveaux qui sont élevés en europe
donc la bataille n'est pas complètement
gagné et puis les derniers chiffres donc
du barreau et de santé avec les
présidents des précautions de
comparaison que j'ai voté en début de
production sur l'autoroute a26 montrent
que les l'année 2020 qui était la fin
des ptic de hausse des prix du tabac a
montré effectivement sur le premier
semestre 2010 une certaine
alors peut dire décélération de la
baisse une augmentation légère du niveau
de consommation quotidienne de tabac qui
a qui incite à la vigilance mais je
pense que jean-michel de l'huile le le
signera également voilà sur les sur le
tabac et l'alcool qui sont les
principaux produits consommés sur le
cannabis qui ne doit pas être un peu
étonnant de l'associer au tabac et
alcool drogues illicites
néanmoins le niveau de diffusion de ce
produit en france depuis vingt ans est
aussi lui marqué par une diffusion très
très large puisque aujourd'hui on a
environ 45 % des adultes 1 franc 1
adulte sur deux qui a déjà expérimenté
le cannabis alors que nous avions que 12
% des adultes
il ya 25 ans donc on a une un produit
qui s'est diffusée comme toute
expérimentation à partir du moment où on
expérimentateurs un jour on le reste est
donc ça reste avec nous dont la vie est
donc ça vient nourrir un stock de d'ex
présentateur mais ce qui change aussi le
disco à la perception que le que peut
avoir notre nos concitoyens sur sur ce
produit et dans le même temps cette
augmentation effectuons des exportateurs
se traduit par un changement qui est
parfois peut-être contre-intuitif c'est
à dire que autant chez les jeunes on
reste à un niveau élevé de
d'exploitation de consommation de
cannabis et des adolescents mais qui est
en baisse sur les 20 dernières années
alors quand est ce qu'ils étaient en
hausse celles et les adultes et donc les
personnes devenues majeures entrée dans
la vie active continue en fait avoir des
niveaux de consommation qui sont plus
élevés que leurs aînés et donc qui
aujourd'hui fait que on a des usagers
dans la nuit et de cannabis qui sont à
11% chez des adultes alors que l'on
était à 4 pourtant il ya 25 ans et 10
triplement aussi en 25 ans et c'est donc
une hausse qui est porté aujourd'hui on
va dire par les 18 45 ans et non pas par
et ne pas parler mineurs donc à un
changement aussi majeur de comportement
qui peut aussi s'expliquer sur les
discours que l'on peut avoir sur le
cannabis avec un élément là de
prévention également les produits que
l'on consomme aujourd'hui qu'elles ont
peu accès d'aujourd'hui sont extrêmement
différents de ceux du début des 90 c'est
à dire que les produits avec beaucoup
plus de thc le principe actif beaucoup
plus important qui nécessite là aussi
des éléments de vigilance voilà sur le
sur cet état des lieux
je vous répète trop long c'est vraiment
un projet très introductif pour pouvoir
répondre à vos questions ensuite on
pourra revenir sur les les dernières
données effectivement de pallier à la
crise sanitaire mais je pense que jean
michel delisle qui est lui était de la
fellation élection aura des éléments de
praticiens qui je pense les clairons
aussi votre commission et puis on pourra
répondre à vos questions ensuite merci
beaucoup de ses propos introductifs
docteur de l'île surpasse la parole
merci madame la présidente mesdames
messieurs je suis au regret de battre
parmi vous j'aurais pu apprécier de vous
rejoindre au palais du luxembourg mais
le moment où la méditation est arrivé
j'avais déjà une journée
donc imaginez bien rempli d'autant plus
que nous venons de recevoir dans nos
centres nos premiers vaccins rnm la
semaine dernière et comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer là il ya une demande assez
forte de la part de nos usagers qui
étaient un peu réticents
astrazeneca dont disposait auparavant
je salue également julien morel d'arleux
les travaux doivent dtn sont absolument
essentielles chantera type ce qui nous
donne une toile de fond qui nous permet
de mieux adapter nos propres
orientations en matière de prévention et
de soins
effectivement ce que je vais vous
présenter en propos liminaire c'est un
écho un petit peu
l'ide hâtif par rapport aux données
quantitatives que vient de nous rappeler
julien la question qui met des causes et
les effets de la crise sanitaire dans
dans nos eaux prises en charge dans les
accompagnements ont suivi je parle au
nom de la fédération addiction mais
aussi en tant qu'acteur de terrain
puisque je suis directeur d'un certain à
ce matin dans un centre de soins
d'addictologie à bordeaux mais toujours
praticiens en l'occurrence au psychiatre
donc il y aura un témoignage de terrain
est par ailleurs en tant que président
la fédération addiction
je bénéficie aussi des retours de mes
collègues au niveau national de la
fédération à peu près 80% des centres de
soins d'accompagnement en version de la
technologie l'examen mais aussi 80 90 %
je pense des centres d'accueil et
d'accompagnement à la réduction des
risques pour les usagers de drogues et
par ailleurs on a également un pôle
médecine générale des addictions et
permet d'entrer dans le milieu
hospitalier
or la crise sanitaire vous avez très
bien dit c'est à dire elle a eu un
impact majeur au niveau de la santé
mentale c'est évidemment une période
totalement anxiogène pour tout le monde
on était inquiet pour choir ses proches
pour sa famille on est inquiets d'une
certaine manière pour la société mais on
était aussi inquiet pour son avenir
économique pour son avenir social et de
fait il faut pas perdre de vue que cette
anxiété sociale cette adversité sociales
immédiates se comble est maintenant il y
est peut-être à la crise économique et
sociale qui s'ensuit donc un impact
anxiogène tp saugeen qui a pu être
évaluée au niveau national vous savez
des enquêtes régulières santé publique
france la 22e arrêté en mars dernier
elle nous disait que 20% et auprès des
des français signalé des éléments
évoquant un syndrome dépressif c'est 10
points par rapport à avant la crise donc
c'est une augmentation tout à fait
considérable et les troubles anxieux
pareil en arrivèrent important donc +7
points et demi et de la même manière des
idées suicidaires était à 9% à peu près
des français c'est-à-dire plus de 4
points par rapport à la phase antérieure
les bonnes nouvelles la vague récente
actuellement
a tendance à s'atténuer dont la première
fois depuis le début du confinement
on commence à assister légère décrue lui
on parle effectivement dans les vaccins
les beaux jours qui reviennent les
ouvertures des gaffes et ses bons jours
est il que ce qui était pour tout le
monde
terriblement que nos gènes les
déstabilisant on imagine bien que pour
les personnes qui présentent des
problèmes d'addiction irene ralement
aussi un des vénérables it et
psychologiques et sociales notamment les
addictions sévère qu'on rencontre dans
nos centres des problèmes d'alcool de
problèmes de tabac bien sûr mais aussi
des problèmes de drogue ces personnes là
on le sait ont pris l'habitude qu'il du
temps d'être tellement débordés
finalement d'affect négatifs comme des
éléments qui les aident
malgré tout à tenir le coup à
anesthésier leurs souffrances à
s'apaiser
ce sont les usages de produits typo3
père sait que c'est un des facteurs de
risque majeurs en fait de la transition
vers l'abus et la dépendance quand on
dit que ça j'ai c'est quand l' usage de
substances ou de pratiques addictives
comme des écrans va avoir un effet de
recherche d'apaisement par rapport à une
tension intérieure
donc autant dire au moment où le le
confinement le premier confinement est
arrivé on s'attendait justice parce que
chez les personnes dépendantes
il y est le risque d'une augmentation
des consommations et où cela pourrait
les mettre en danger
si bien que nos premières préoccupations
ça a été de rester ouvert et je dois
dire que c'est une fierté pour le
secteur médico social en addictologie
les carrupt sont restés ouverts laissera
pas résidentiels sont restés ouverts et
les que sa part ambulatoire eux ont pu
continuer à exercer leur activité
souvent développant des pratiques de
visio avec deux prix aux conférences
néanmoins ça a été très important parce
qu'à bordeaux par exemple dans le carré
le premier jour du profil on a vu
arriver des gens de la rue qui n'avait
plus un centime parce qu'il y avait plus
de personnes dans les rues et donc il
pouvait plus vivre de la manche des
centres qu'il pensait de la nourriture
était fermé quand ils sont animés par
des bénévoles cependant certain âge qui
donc très légitimement avait dû
interrompre leurs activités
si bien qu'on a été envahie en fait de
demandes d'ordre de besoins primaires
iman terre et autres qu'on a complété
évidemment par des kits d'hygiène mais
qu'on a complété aussi par un souci
essentiel d assurer la poursuite des
traitements de substitution sans
interruption de risque sinon que des
inégalités d'approvisionnement en train
de démarrer à sion tolérance manqué un
excès de décès par heure aux à jojo
pioline et la même manière on a essayé
de faire en sorte de maintenir l'accès
au maintien d'une réduction des risques
or sur les traitements de substitution
sa démarche et les des relations été
immédiate avec la direction générale la
santé je les appelle sollicités ils ont
répondu immédiatement et pendant toute
la période du 1er confinement nous
avions des rendez vous hebdomadaire avec
la direction générale de la santé ce qui
a permis d'avoir les assouplissements
réglementaires quand on connaît en
termes de prescriptions délivrance de
traitement de substitution
les renouvellements automatiques en
pharmacie la possibilité de prescrire à
distance et tout ça nous a permis de
faire en sorte qu'il n'y en eut pas eu
de diminution de l'accessibilité aux
traitements de substitution y compris
pendant neuf ans le confinement
il ya même une légère augmentation de
l'accès grâce à l'activité des dès que
sa part ce qui fait qu'on a modéré dans
anciennement l'excès de décès par
surdose qui était attendue en france
les données sont pas encore stabilisés
de l'enquète drame en forme et aux
alentours de + 10 % + 15 % à peu près de
décès par overdose dans cette période
par rapport à l époque de l'année
antérieure
dans certains états des états unis brou
donner un exemple du canada dont on
avait le réseau international des taux
d'augmentation c'était plus 100 % + 150
% + 2 100 % dans certains états donc on
voit que ça ça a fonctionné dans une
façon là on a vu inventé des systèmes
d'aller vers comme pour des raisons de
demander ce passe une partie de nos
personnels en quarts une notamment ne
pouvait pas exercer leur activité dans
le sens parce qu'on avait parlé des
volumes de distanciation sociale
suffisante
on a pu développer des actions d'aller
vers notamment dans les centres de
desserrement ce qui nous a permis de
travailler avec des équipes sociales et
ça c'est une des leçons à retenir
également pour la suite
c'est une meilleure intégration des
équipes sociales et des équipes
sanitaires comme les neuf autres pour
aller ou de vendre et des personnes en
situation de grande de grande précarité
dans de même ordre
d'ailleurs nous avons collaboré petit la
fédération duction avec la direction
logement pour essayer de donner une
autre orientation centres d'hébergement
d'urgence entre d'observance entre 2 ou
chrs et nouveau faire en sorte qu'ils
aient une âme une application plus
ouvertes de leur règlement intérieur de
telle manière entrer dans des politiques
de réduction des risques par
consommation d'alcool et de depuis m en
préalable l'arrêt de toute consommation
parce qu'on savait que ça m'était deux
côtés des gens qui se sentait incapable
de s'abstenir surtout dans cette période
là qui on le rappelle était
particulièrement un parti qui manque
chez eux j'ai donc au total entre les
développements de la télétransmission
des téléconsultations des politiques
d'aller vers on a pu réussir à tenir le
coup mais on partait de loin puisqu'un d
un des constats qu'on avait dû faire
avec la direction générale de la santé
ce que notre secteur est très
particulier parce qu'on est un peu en
dehors des radars comme nous on est dans
un monde un spécifique population entité
spécifique ce qui fait qu'on était
complètement oublié initialement
évidemment pour les équipements de
protection évidemment pour les jets de
pierre mais aussi pour les gardes
d'enfants à temps tout ceci a pu être
remis en place et je dois dire que notre
visibilité pendant de celle de nos
équipes mobiles dans les draps fp certes
c'est à pendant cette période nous a
permis clairement de rentrer en fait
dans les clous du politique de santé si
bien que actuellement par exemple aussi
bien pour les les tests de dépistage il
ya quelques mois et maintenant pour des
vaccins nous sommes réellement intégrées
dans les circuits de distribution
officiel est formel et nous pouvons
jouer notre rôle auprès des populations
des populations et plus le les plus
précaires donc un des constats qui a
émergé en fait de cette période là et on
a beaucoup travaillé avec la dial sur ce
thème là c'est que pour faire face à ses
problèmes de précarité il fallait pas se
faire mais sûrement sur une offre de
soins dans vos techniques
il fallait vraiment une approche globale
avec une offre d'hébergement adapté mais
aussi avec une offre pour ce qui de qui
le souhaitent notamment les jeunes de
retour au travail avec des modalités
particulières comme le dispositif
d'apache alors juste une dernière
parenthèse et je m'en tiendrai là la
problématique
des jeunes julien l'a évoqué tout à
l'heure dans ce contexte stressant
général les jeunes ont payé un tribut
encore plus lourd puisque les jeunes
notamment les adolescents c'est au plan
psychologique c'est la tranche d'âge
dans notre visite où on a le plus besoin
des autres en fait d autres jeunes du
groupe de pain ce qui fait que la
période de confinement de d'isolement
par rapport aux autres jeunes
d'isolement aussi par rapport à la
communauté éducative d'isolement et de
craintes par rapport à son avenir
l'incertitude sur les examens sur les
apprentissages le fait parfois de se
retrouver pour les plus vulnérables dans
des espaces très resserrée au plan
familial parfois avec des conceptions
fait que l'aller l'augmentation des dd
problème évidemment a été majeur a
bordeaux par exemple des services de
pédopsychiatrie période qui a suivi les
pros finement c'était plus 70 % de
demandes d'hospitalisation par rapport à
la période antérieure c'est du jamais lu
du jamais vu avec du coude et des
recours pour certains d'entre eux à des
usages de cannabis comme on a été dit ça
a été dit à part julien un arrêt de la
diminution du tabagisme dans cette
population là une augmentation majeure
des pratiques d'écran une augmentation
des pratiques de jeux d'argent et de
jeux en ligne une augmentation des
pratiques de boulimie un arrêt des
pratiques sportives une prise de poids
et c'est donc un ensemble de mécanismes
qui contribuent à aggraver les choses
mais là aussi je voulais juste rester
sur quelques propos un peu un peu
généraux pour donner place à la
discussion et je suis tout à fait
partisan maintenant des changes direct
s'achetant aucune des données avec qui
nous a vraiment frappé c'était données
américaines je pense qu'elles sont
intéressantes à utiliser quand utilisé
en france c'est comme pendant la période
de confinement comme les gens ne
pouvaient pas se déplacer un peu partout
dans le monde et notamment chez nous il
ya une diminution d admission en
hospitalisation en urgence
simplement les gens pouvaient pas se
déplacer parce qu'il s'était bloquée
parce que plus personne ne bougeait mais
ce qui est important à noter c'est que
ça les personnes qui malgré tout
finissait pas arriver ou dans les
services d'urgence la part relative des
facteurs causaux dire quelles sont les
causes de ces
ce utilisation c'étaient les addictions
les surdosages des tentatives de suicide
des troubles du comportement les
violences intrafamiliales dont
clairement on était dans cette spirale
santé mentale et addictions comme comme
motif et c'est ce qu'on a essayé de
présenter au ministre monsieur des
rentes qui mouraient notre journée à
section est trouble psychiatrique comme
un ce dernier en théorie mais il servait
sentais que c'était comme aujourd'hui la
radio en parlant de scinder me dire
quand y'a un regroupement synergie pic
entre des épidémies en virale des
problèmes secondaires psychiatriques des
problèmes sociaux et son surdéterminé
par des vulnérables si bien
qu'actuellement on va évidemment mettre
l'accent sur les personnes qui sont en
situation de grande vulnérabilité
sociale
voilà quelques quelques mots généraux de
retour on veut plus le qualitatif
merci monsieur le président je fais
passer à paroles tout de suite à apposer
une écologie rapport auquel f la mission
des cas merci madame la présidente merci
messieurs pour vous exposer successifs
j'ai trois questions l'évaluation
scientifique de l'inserm a très
récemment confirmé l'intérêt des salles
de consommation à moindre risque
pourriez-vous nous exposer les
conclusions de cette enquête et nous
détailler les freins d'ouverture aux
nouvelles salles de consommation à
moindre risque
une deuxième question en france 80% des
décès par surdose sont dues aux opiacés
aux opioïdes pas bon pour rappel le
maine un médicament antidote la manne
look sound existe sous forme prête à
l'emploi
utilisable par tous depuis plus de deux
ans désormais ce kit de mal auxonne
c'est disponible en pharmacie sans
prescription médicale gratuitement à
l'hôpital et dans les structures
d'addictologie
et permet permettent à chaque témoin
d'une surdose d'agir dans la tente des
secours est ce que cela fonctionne
les usagers sont ils sont ils emparés de
ces médicaments
peut-on estimer le nombre de surdoses
aux hôpitaux aux opioïdes aux opiacés
évité grâce à ce médicament
et enfin une troisième question qui
concerne le cannabis est la mission de
l'assemblée nationale sur le cannabis a
rendu ce printemps un rapport d'étape
qui fait le constat de l'échec de la
politique répressive depuis plus de 50
ans tant en termes de sécurité que de
santé publique
quel est votre sentiment quant à ces
conclusions notamment ce qui concerne
les usages récréatifs du cannabis ce
gros mercier eh bien je vais peut-être
prendre deux autres intervenants
globalement les questions sont courtes
et précises
michel meunier ensuite voir une inverse
merci merci à vous sur le directeur j'ai
une question concernant ce qu'on appelle
la diction s'en produit donc je suis de
nantes est un ampli fac de nantes mène
des recherches notamment dans ce domaine
et montre bien qu'il approche des
comportements est une approche
intéressante et je voulais vous
s'entendre là-dessus sur le docteur de
lille a abordé à la fin de son
intervention tout ce qui était écran et
et cyber et autres comporte les jeux etc
donc c'était sur l' approche plutôt que
sur le comportement plutôt que sur les
produits
et puis je voulais vous demander aussi
en profitent et peut-être docteur de
lille plus particulièrement
j'ai été contacté il ya un moment
maintenant par les proches aidants des
malades alcooliques qui vivent au
quotidien
parfois parfois l'enfer et hell on
wheels on sait les deux colis sme touche
aussi les femmes
ils ont fait elles ont l'impression de
ne pas être entendus et reconnus et
soutenus dans leur quotidien et je
voulais savoir si vous aviez eu monsieur
docteur de lille avec le ministre véran
l'occasion d'aborder cette question de
l'alcoolisme
merci corinne imbert merci à la
présidente merci à vous deux pour tous
vos propos en complément de la question
de ma collègue brigitte nicouleau sur
sur les salles de consommation à moindre
risque
mais c'est peut-être aussi compris dans
sa question c'est quel regard
portez-vous sur cette expérimentation
qui va qui va se déterminer
plus largement sur la politique de lutte
contre les contre les addictions en tant
que rapporteur pour l'assurance maladie
sur la réponse médicale qui est apportée
avez-vous a suivi nombre de
consultations vue d'une prise en charge
des addictions et sur la prescription de
traitements de substitution pour le le
sevrage substances psychoactives
est-ce que les moyens dédiés à la
prévention et à la réduction des risques
on selon vous montrer leur efficacité et
comment pourrait-il être amélioré et en
complément est ce qu'en termes
d'aménagement du territoire les centres
de prise en charge des addictions vous
semblent ils suffisants et facilement
accessible et puis dans votre votre
petit document qui vient faire et c'est
peut-être volonté il n'y a pas
d'éléments chiffrés entre les addictions
chez les hommes et chez les femmes
pour autant quel constat faites vous
justement ces addictions chez chez la
femme y compris quand elle est enceinte
moi je suis frappé par des jeunes femmes
qui continuent à fumer largement pendant
là pendant la grossesse et j'avoue que
ça m'effraie évidemment donc que ce soit
à tabac alcool et y compris y compris la
pharmacodépendance quelles propositions
fourier vous sur ce sujet je vous
remercie donc je vous laisse répondre
peut-être le début a à ces questions et
ensuite le professeur de le pendre à une
question qui lui sont plus
spécifiquement des destiny merci pour
l'ensemble de ces questions
difficile d'y répondre de manière
succincte et surtout exhaustive puisque
certains travaux ne relève pas de
l'obsar français des drogues et
toxicomanies concernant l'évaluation qui
a été menée sur les salles de
consommation à moindre risque par une
équipe de l'inserm
alors pour qui fait 650 pages que
j'avoue moi même n'avons pas lu dans son
intégralité
je pense me souvenais deux points sur
ceux sur soi pour d'abord c'est
souligner que la qualité du travail qui
était menée par les petites public est
parlé par les équipes de recherche pour
réaliser alors que c'était une
explantation dans les délais de cette
exploitation une première évaluation
avec des moyens importants et une
rigueur scientifique qui permettent
d'avoir des résultats qui viennent
aujourd'hui conforté ce que l'on a dans
les autres pays européens
il ya ce type de salles de consommation
à moindre risque existe il a plus d'une
huître façon de 80 salles qui est guide
on a quelque chose qui est déjà avec un
désert est excellente et qui fonctionne
dans notre pays et je sais que
jean-michel ligne nouvelle va me
contredire souvent si on compare des
pays autres pays européens on n'a pas
une telle différence culturelle entre
nos pays qui fait que ce qui fonctionne
dans un pays ne fonctionnerait pas dans
le nôtre
donc on voit bien que cette
expérimentation avec les moyens qui sont
dédiés montre que l'un des objectifs
principaux est de réduire les risques
pour les usagers de drogues
problématique cela fonctionne on a moins
d'exposition au au surdosage -
l'exposition aux aux accidents qui
peuvent être liés à l'injection moins
d'exposition moins d'infections au vih
ou au ps c'est donc dans le cadre de ce
travail là cadre ait que tient
extrêmement important des professionnels
d'accompagnement dont l'usagé de drogues
problématique est donc on est vraiment
dans une chaussure des résultats qui
sont vraiment encourageants en la
matière avec un élément mais je pense
que votre commission la vienne en tête
qui dément de
d'acceptabilité sociale de ce type de
salle notre pays à qui reste un sujet de
tension le tout un volet de l'étude
traite de ce sujet avec la parole donnée
à ceux qui sont pour et ceux qui sont
contre
principalement dans le quartier puisque
on est on est sûr valent pas un
phénomène qui cristallise dans un espace
ce qui est intéressant et on a trahi nos
êtres l'inserm sur sur ce volet-là sur
l'activité globale des débuts de
réduction des risques sera aussi avec
une partie d'autres questions finalement
les français et on le mesure nous dans
notre enquête qui s'appelle ehrhoff qui
menait depuis 20 ans que le premier en
plus de vingt ans puisque le premier
gars si c'est lui en 99 sur les
représentations des français sur la
question des drogues
cette enquête europe entre 99 et 2018
2019 la dernière année on l'a réalisé
- bien qu'ils aient une plus grande
acceptabilité des mesures de réduction
des risques parce que et on allait faire
un focus spécifique puisque on était
juste après le lancement d'exploitation
2016 sur les salles de consommation à
moindre risque
et lorsqu'on présente cet équipement
l'objectif c'est bien protégés et
réduire les risques des usagers de
drogues et assurer une meilleure
tranquillité publique puis d aspect sur
lequel la salle de compression à moins
de risques ont été ont été évalués dans
le pays on voit bien que on a 80 % des
des français interrogés qui sont
favorables à ce à ce type de sam et
surtout 75% 76% qui est défavorable à la
toute nouvelle salle et surtout quand
même c'est important parce qu'on avait
posé la question une troisième un
troisième niveau de questions s'est dit
favorable si ce type de salle est ouvert
dans votre quartier et une majorité
d'alors 52% donc moi on voit bien que
fur et à mesure qu'on se rapproche de
ses soual le l'acceptabilité des
tableaux appartenant on reste quand même
sur une majorité de français qui ce qui
était favorable
donc on voit bien voilà donc c'est enfin
c'est un ce sont des êtres qui
fonctionne à l'étranger qui ont prouvé
depuis maintenant une dizaine d'années
leur efficacité pour réduire les risques
est dommage et c'est le
l'objectif principal de ces salles et
donc le le rapport de l'inserm moi je
vous rend plutôt d'avoir ses conclusions
et extrêmement détaillées et montre en
tout cas que c'est comme le mil des
calottes lumière une évaluation qui est
qui est favorable
un 2e alain sais pas s'il y avait
effectivement une question sur tout ce
que là encore en matière de réduction
des risques et de prévention des décès
par surdose avec oxo je pense que c'est
le gym 3 plus facilement répondre sur la
vie de la maison a mis en oeuvre la
description de ces kits de l'actionner
lille
les les difficultés et et laurence et
ont pu être constatés sur sur le terrain
on est quand même là aussi sur des
mesures qui sont on retrouve dans
d'autres pays européens
il faut savoir que dans le cadre du
rapport européen sur les drogues on voit
bien que en matière de prévention et
d'accessibilité aux traitements de
substitution en france on est le pays un
des pays en europe avec le plus fort
taux de couverture pour les usagers de
drogues problématiques d'accès d'accès à
ces traitements
je vous renvoie au tableau de bord sous
traitement de substitution que l'on
publie chaque année à la dt sur sur ce
sur ce sujet
voilà une tête un dernier point avant de
revenir si j'ai aussi certains points un
jour viendra ensuite sur la question de
la mission sur le parlementaire
internationale sur la légalisation
législation fois cannabis pardon sur les
addictions comportementales c'est un
sujet qui est nouveau entre pas pour pas
dans le temps pas dans le champ mais qui
nous vaut pour l'observatoire français
des drogues et des toxicomanies sur
lequel on s'est engagé donc depuis un an
atteint avec la reprise des missions de
l'observatoire des jeux sur les jeux
d'argent et de hasard à travailler ça
reste les jeux d'argent et de hasard
la première addictions sont produits
deux en france on a une réflexion qui
est en cours aujourd'hui au tour de
monde et autres addictions entendu qu'on
pourrait suivre sachant qu effectivement
le l'insu français de l'addiction
comportementale donc les faca non plus
un chantier très très large pour notre
observatoire on compte dans un premier
temps travaille d'abord sur huit mois
les jeux d'argent et de hasard donc la
mission qui nous a été confiée par des
crêpes
les dernières et ensuite au tour des
troubles de l'usaj du jeu vidéo tout
parce que on parle beaucoup de vous
parler d'addiction aux écrans sur quatre
cette commission et sans vous en achetez
chacun un écran apporté à portée de main
moi j'en ai en face de moi mais j'en ai
deux dans mon sac je vous rassure on est
tous donc ya pas un trouble de l'usaj de
l'écran directe c'est-à-dire comme le
disait on a un outil on lui on le
mobilise à quel moment effectivement on
va être dans une dent dans un usage qui
va être qui va venir compenser
finalement et c'est toute la question
effectivement 2
reportage comportementale finalement
qu'est-ce que comportement vient
traduire des des troubles que l'on peut
avoir est de ce que l'on va rechercher
puisque l'usager va rechercher en
utilisant de manière excessive ces
outils donc on a autour des jeux vidéo
on voit bien et en particulier chez les
adolescents on est en train de mener à
la demande de la ville des cas
actuellement une enquête exploratoire
sur le visage de jeux vidéo chez les
collégiens pour avoir des éléments de
connaissance également que le souligner
je me suis dit tout à l'heure par
rapport aussi à des évolutions de
comportement qu'elle a pu avoir lieu ces
derniers mois avec le fait d'être
enfermé chez soi donc donc on interroge
des collégiens autour des jeux vidéo on
a volontairement resserrer la fondation
c'était sur cet exploit sur les plus
jeunes visages et de jeux vidéo donc on
aura des résultats en fin d'année début
d'année de 2022
ça c'est un élément qui d'importants qui
est devant nous notre collège
scientifique a été renouvelé en 2000 en
début d'année 2021 avec la volonté de
d'augmenter nos travaux sur les
addictions comportementales dans l'est
dans les prochaines années
enfin sur la mission d'information
parlementaire moi je dirais enfin il ya
les travaux là aussi qu'ils sont de plus
d'un an l'été a été au même titre les
fellations élections quinzaine d'acteurs
teint auditionnés
là aussi on voit orange évoqués ci
j'évoquais tout à l'heure les les
évolutions des usages et d'exportation
de cannabis depuis 25 ans au pays on
voit bien qu'il ya changement de regard
par rapport à la consommation de
cannabis avec la mission d'information
parlementaire a lancé une grande
consultation mots qui ont répondu à
certaines personnes qui étaient
intéressés par pas la consultation donc
avec il faut on va comparer les chiffres
de cette consultation avec d'autres
sondages qui peuvent être réalisés nous
si on vous le disait en début notamment
si on est attentif aux méthodes de deux
enquêtes et comparabilité entre les
enquêtes donc je vais reprendre notre
enquête europe qui n'a aussi leur en a
20 ans de recul et on voit bien qu'on
attend la perception sur la légalisation
ou le changement de réglementation
materi cannabis a changé depuis
depuis la pole
le premier résultat en 1989 reprend 499
je mettrai moins un point qui est
extrêmement important qui peut éclairer
aussi le débat plus on voit bien en 2018
avec eropp que le changement de regard
sur légalisation du cannabis
en fait on a adopté trois ans c'était 45
% des répondants des adultes qui se
déclaraient favorables à une
légalisation du cannabis là où les
chiffres semaine dernière d'un autre
nation 51%
on est dans un envoi bien quand on est
on est on est sur un niveau qui reste
aux comparables
mais ce qui est vraiment intéressant
c'est que suivant le statut séduction ça
vous est expérimenté le cannabis ou pas
en fait ça va du simple au triple c'est
à dire que on à 29% des noms
expérimentateur de cannabis qui sont des
femmes qui sont favorables à la
législation sur le cannabis et 65% des
exportateurs qui le sont donc on a bien
le ses 45% sont très tranchés et ça
montre bien que cette défaite diffusion
c'est ce qu'on a connu aussi dans les
pays d'amérique du nord c'est à dire
c'est parce que c'est venu par les
citoyens de ces deux de ses états au
canada ou aux états unis les affaires
qui ont légalisé le cannabis aux états
unis la plupart des mouvements sont des
mouvements qui viennent par des
référendums d'initiative locale c'est à
dire c'est les citoyens qui demandent ce
changement de législation
seuls quelques éléments de réponse
docteur des lignes pour compléter oui je
vous remercie pour toutes ces questions
qui vont nous permettre de préciser un
certain nombre de choses alors sur la
salle de consommation longtemps deux
d'entre vous ont évoqué le rapport de
recherche d'une scène qui est vraiment
remarquable puisqu'il y avait une étude
quasiment pas randomisés avec un groupe
gan drôle de casse une étude contrôlée
ce qui est bien comme l'a très bien dit
julien ça confié en grès des bénéfices
en terme de
de santé par rapport à une réduction du
nombre de dover doses auraient mis
représentante des problèmes infectieux
par rapport à une réduction relative de
l'incidence de vih hépatite c et c
ceci c'est une confirmation mais c'est
important les aspects médico économique
je prononce le pavé en gros on se rend
compte que sans être économiseur de
coupes dans les coûts générés sont tout
à fait acceptables
l'aspect relations avec l'environnement
est très liée comme la 10 e julia la
proximité ou pas avec la salle donc moi
ma réflexion d'ensemble par rapport à ce
rapport ce qui soulève quand même une
question où on voit que les résultats ne
sont pas à la hauteur des attentes dans
le domaine de l'accès aux soins
c'est à dire habituellement les salles
de consoles sont également en premier
lieu de contact avec des usagers qui
sont très éloignées du soin compris la
réduction des risques et qui ont
uniquement dans des logiques de
transformation et où il est tout à fait
important de pouvoir saisir cette
opportunité pour peut-être aussi leur
offrir des possibilités de passage vers
d'autres formes d'accompagnement
pourquoi pas le soin par rapport à la
diction mais aussi par rapport à
l'hébergement à quelque chose de l'ordre
d'une d'une action veut plus un peu plus
globale
et là on se rend compte en tout cas que
dans dans ces expériences là par rapport
à notre expérience qu'on peut avoir à
l'étranger il ya eu des résultats qui
étaient moins moins enthousiasmant ce
qui nous laisse supposer qu'il ya une
marge de progression
tout à fait important à mon avis à
l'avenir de faire en sorte que le
développement des salles de consommation
qui se faire de manière beaucoup plus
intégrée peu par rapport au dispositif
général de soins dans le domaine des
addictions
d'autre part ça permettrait aussi
d'envisager quelque chose qui nous
permettrait de réduire les difficultés
de lier à la tranquillité publique et
aux éventuelles nuisances de voisinage
je peux l'une des idées qui nous est
cher la russie sur la base expérience
européenne
c'est plutôt sort à paris la prétendue
besoins sont massifs mais d'adapter
vraiment le niveau de réponse aux
besoins aux besoins locaux
et notamment d'être envisagé plusieurs
petits dispositifs dispersé plutôt que
des gros dispositif de concentration et
pourquoi pas permettre à certains cas
rue dans des structures déjà existantes
qui sont déjà en place d'avoir des
politiques des de la réduction des
risques dus aux injections mais
également d'être dans certaines cas de
pratiques contrôler pour notre part à
bandeau pas on est également favorable
au dispositif mobile et qui permet sans
déranger des quartiers d'avoir quand
même une réponse qui va au devant des
personnes
donc évidemment tout à fait favorables
au développement de ces salles en france
votre pérennisation ici possible on
adapte dans justement leur mode de
fonctionnement noté façon qu'elle soit
peut-être encore plus vous intégré dans
le dispositif général sur la question
des overdoses et de la naloxone vous
avez tout à fait raison un bibelot pour
la plupart les décès sont liés à et
désintoxication aux opioïdes avant des
opioïdes illégaux de l'héroïne des
opioïdes détournés de leur usage est
parfois des traitements de substitution
à prades et de la morphine
médicamenteuse mais également d'un poids
des les opioïdes qui sont commandés sur
internet avec une préoccupation
croissante par rapport à des produits
extrêmement puissants comme du sainte
anne des monts du klpd c est dernière de
septembre dans le sud-ouest auriez une
réponse effectivement la naloxone est ce
qu'elle est suffisamment utilisé la
réponse est claire non puisque le
dispositif le plus acceptable par les
usagers qui est le plus simple à
utiliser surtout dans un contexte en
boîte il ya une overdose en cours ce
sont les dispositifs par ce théâtre
anase a clairement et il se trouve que
le premier médicament qui avaient été
proposées c'était le match qu il n'y a
pas eu d'accord tarifaire entre les
autorités de santé l'ars et la firme
industrielle de fait la
commercialisation d'une action est
interrompu en france il fait
qu'actuellement nous n'avons plus plein
de produits à disposition
le voilà ce que l'occident qui est un
jeune également mais en intramusculaire
petit peu plus compliqué il ya une
préparation et de fait le pulp au
lancement de
à l'aube sonne à renaître à nasale fait
eux les gens ne sont pas appropriés
suffisamment sans doute ce dispositif en
légende c'est les professionnels mais
c'est aussi les usagers vous savez les
usagers sont pas très demandeur ce genre
de substance les antagonismes au pc il
s'en méfier un petit peu pour des tables
pour des tas de raisons
et donc elle nécessite est vraiment d'un
travail de motivation auprès des usagers
en espère il devait y avoir une
troisième forme une troisième galénique
de nan auxonne toujours en n3 a qui
doivent être mis sur le marché
ce début d'année le nic solide là aussi
il ya des discussions
ça n'avance pas beaucoup alors on nous
annonce maintenant que ça pourra peut
être être à l'automne bien une réelle le
clan ce de diversifier les formes de
présentation d'un à auxonne et notamment
d'avoir la possibilité de prescrire de
données de remettre directement les
formes et ranaz alpes sont beaucoup plus
le bronze acceptable sur le cannabis
récréatif et la notion mais pour m lyon
joue pas grand chose à rajouter à ce que
disait julien ça traduit effectivement
l'évolution des représentations plan
international avec toutes les campagnes
et les actions de l'égalisation qui ont
eu lieu dans pas mal de deux contres et
maintenant mais également au plan
au plan national il ya un élément qui
est assez classe que disait julien
initialement d'ailleurs c'est
qu'actuellement
là où les tranches d'âge les usages la
prévalence d usage de cannabis augmente
c'est des gens adultes où il ya un effet
de translation finalement générationnel
où les jeunes dit bien dix ou quinze ans
maintenant 30 35 40 ans et pour certains
se sont accrochés ils ont amené avec eux
un certain nombre de ses consommations
il répond aussi aux sondages et envoyé
que ceux qui sont consommateurs une
attitude évidemment très particulière
par rapport à l'appréciation ce domaine
parce qu'on a constaté c'est que le
cannabis n'est pas une drogue qui a
systématiquement des effets délétères
majeurs c'est à dire beaucoup d'usagers
arrive à avoir des consommations à peu
près à peu près contrôler et donc le
regard sur le cannabis est sans doute du
fait de cette reconnaissance-là être moi
totalement négatif qu'il pouvait l'être
dans les années 70-80 en majorité des
français
aucune expérience
là et donc c'était néanmoins le bullet
sens de cette affaire-là c'est que de
plus en plus de jeunes et d'adultes sont
rendus compte que c'était pas non plus
une panacée c'est à dire sa poupée
déclenché que les problèmes ce qui fait
que actuellement au fur à mesure que le
temps passe finalement on se rend compte
que c'est une molécule de thc en
l'occurrence qui non seulement peut
avoir des effets délétères sur la santé
sur les commissions sur la concentration
des risques au volant des risques au
travail des risques de violences
également mais surtout c'est assez
redoutable chez les jeunes chez les ados
et notamment quand on commence à
utiliser avant 15h ou là on va ramener
sain et durable en termes de nouveaux
développements si bien que ça va
peut-être vous étonner mais alors que la
fédération addiction héritière de
l'association des intervenants en
toxicomanie qui avait pris parti et qui
maintient d'ailleurs en 1994 pour
l'organisation du du cannabis puisqu'on
voit bien toutes les limites de la
prohibition
notre rôle peut-être en termes d'acteurs
de santé publique actuellement c'est
plutôt de tempérer l'enthousiasmé des
personnes naïves et qui vont être sous
pression également de lobby on voit
l'importance des lobbys du cannabis au
plan international avec beaucoup
diraient l'industrie du tabac
si bien qu' on est plutôt enfin tout à
fait favorable à une des prohibitions
métis entrerait dans son cadre vraiment
de régulation très contrôlés et
notamment qui ne vit pas saturé sur leur
maintien de l'interdît pour les jeunes
dans certains styles de deux des espaces
de consommation qui peuvent présenter
des dangers
je ne veux pas c'est khelil que make a
ensuite y avait les questions sur les
addictions comportementales moi ce type
et attendra évidemment les éléments qui
comporte un couteau me passionne on est
en lien étroit depuis jean luc vénisse
les avec l'équipe actuelle de de l'ifac
c'est clairement un problème émergent
qui a été accéléré je pense par la
période du confinement pour les raisons
que j'ai tout à l'heure et plus
particulièrement chez les jeunes c'est
là où il ya le problème majeur
on sait que les écrans indépendamment
d'une annexion de sont toxiques ou en
deux ans trois ans est stable mais pour
ce qui nous intéresse nous côté addict
aux on se rend compte que c'est vraiment
un piège
puisque c'est un facteur de d'isolement
social croissant et on s'en rend compte
par le fait que les jeunes qui perdent
le contrôle pas un euro aux écrans sont
souvent des jeunes qui justement sont
vulnérabilité psychologique qui ont des
problèmes de de vie difficiles soit dans
leur famille joue en milieu scolaire qui
peuvent être harcelé qui ont des phobies
sociales
les phobies scolaires etc et qui trouve
dans les écrans un espace a simplement
distraction mais là aussi un espace un
peu auto thérapeutique au moins deux ans
c'est à dire quelque chose qui va les
amener à avoir des actions valorisée
valorisantes où ils ont un espace lewis
ordre totalement de leur isolement
toutes les études montrent deux études
prospectives que hélas l'écran var comme
la drogue avoir un effet aggravant du
problème initial ce qui à première vue
dans l'immédiat et un effet plutôt
apaisant ensuite contribuer à aggraver
encore l'isolément social et notamment
chez les filles on voit aussi que ce
sont des facteurs des projets c'est à
dire alors les gars ans plus tôt jeux
vidéo je caricature les filles c'est
beaucoup réseaux sociaux c'est à dire le
besoin d'être portés par leurs gardes et
des copains des copines et quand on a
moins de réponses favorables quand on
commence à se moquer lieu de sa tenue ou
qu'on n'a pas de retour aussi positif
que ce qu'on imagine les gens les plus
fragiles vont continuer à s'enfoncer
donc c'est vraiment un enjeu avec un
élément qui a évoqué un julien puisque
maintenant mais les jeux sont entrées
dans le périmètre
c'est une bonne décision de le répéter
il faut être attentif aux paris sportifs
c'est la porte d'entrée actuellement
chez les populations vulnérables dans le
domaine qui cumule la vulnérabilité du
jeu vidéo écran et la vulnérabilité du
jeu d'argent
ça c'est un mélange toxique le début de
l'augmentation c'était 98 fascinant
c'était la dernière coupe du monde 2018
où la france a fait un bon parcours
j'espère que la france pour un bon
parcours pour pour l'euro néanmoins on
sait que c'est des facteurs de risque je
vous invite à revoir les pubs toutes les
mi-temps notamment celle de winamax où
on voit que c'est typiquement centrée
sur des jeunes vulnérables en lieu et où
il ya des images style de roi lion
un type qui est dans un petit salon en
fumée fatigue etc
deviens le roi du monde avec un géant
avec une apothéose
donc on va voir comment cette illusion
de transformation peut être un piège
pour des gens et plus j'en ai vu les
rats socialement psychologiquement plus
en plus que basculer les côtés de 2,7 de
cette affection sur les aidants des
malades pohlig souvent des femmes
avaient effectivement dans notre pays
elle à l'accueil nous encourage
notamment psychiatrie en général mais
dans les hôpitaux il n'est pas excellent
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire mais
c'était souvent perçu comme gênante la
logique actuelle en tout cas des efforts
de formation des décennies en plus moi
je suis thérapeute famille l'a chanté
dansé au contraire de travailler avec
l'environnement familial qui a peut-être
sa part aussi dans l'éclosion du
problème et en tout cas à une part
importante à prendre dans la résolution
du problème est de plus en plus nous
avons des liens très étroits au niveau
national au niveau locaux aussi
l'associer à un milliard avec une femme
et notre part nous essayons également
nous avons fait des projets communs sur
le le guide de survie pour les parents
du psychiatre hic c'est moi qui rédige
et last express addiction non vraiment
on essaie de travailler le plus possible
ensemble et d'intégrer y compris des
pairs aidants et parfois des personnes
liées à la problématique un directement
dans le fonctionnement de nos équipes
non seulement les usagers paient
eux-mêmes mais également leur leur
environnement mais je suis d'accord avec
vous on part de très loin il faut
bouleverser des représentations au
second c'était la famille qui était
jugée plus ou moins responsable du
problème et encore on la mettait un
petit peu à l'écart en passant de
manière illusoire que la séparation n'a
pas un texto me a river est un bon staff
on sait qu'en fait c'est l'inversé qui
se produit donc il faut vraiment être
attendait des logiques de polars
relations de coopération sur des
objectifs thérapeutiques partagé en
abordant les questions leur bien sûr
d'un cm est gelée 10 par rapport à la
discussion sur l'alternative sera jo
substitution réduction des risques
oui il ya une véritable révolution le
savait
ces dernières décennies où
traditionnellement le modèle de
traitement c'était céder le sevrage
l'abstinence
on se rende des comptes que cet objectif
remarquable était tellement ambitieux et
difficile à atteindre
hélas beaucoup de passion nous ne se
sentait pas en mesure de l'atteindre et
du coup s'autocensurer finalement
haineux contacter pas nous nos
structures
donc il ya eu une véritable révolution
il ya longtemps dans le champ des
opiacés avec le traitement de
substitution où en serions-nous compte
plutôt que de se battre à tout prix pour
l'abstinence avec les risques qu'il y
avait eu à l'époque de développement du
sida
il valait mieux partir de la demande des
personnes elles mêmes en l'occurrence
des seringues propres des choses comme
ça en soin de leur santé
limiter les risques de contamination et
sur cette base là essayer de les aider
c'est un peu ce qu'on disait sur les
sacs de constructeurs à accéder des
trains à des objectifs une avancée plus
ambitieux en fonction de deux de leurs
besoins et on s'est rendu compte que
cette politique là nous permettait
d'abord de contact est beaucoup plus de
personnes dans une ambiance pacifié et
qu'au final ça nous permettait d'aider
beaucoup plus de personnes aussi a
évolué vers des traitements réguliers de
traitement de substitution mais il dit
en privé vers le forage et finalement
ces dernières années c'est une tendance
qui s'est développée dans les domaines
de la colle l'emporté encore plus loin
puisque l'objectif cardinal d'abstinence
potable définitive était quelque chose
qu'on apprenait à l'école depuis plus
d'un siècle et où on s'est rendu compte
que du tout où il y avait beaucoup de
gens qui avaient des problèmes d'alcool
qui restait sur le bas côté parce qu'ils
se reconnaissaient pas dans dont on a
changé une de paradigme en disant on va
faire de vos demandes qui m'ont la
demande des gens qui ont une
consommation excessive c'est pas
d'arrêter complètement de quoi c'est
plutôt de revenir avant c'est-à-dire art
maîtriser leur consommation à la mode
elle est hélas de ce côté là maintenant
on a des nouveaux médicaments qui ont
été formatés pour ça c'est pour aider à
soutenir le sevrage maintenant le
baclofène à d'autres il ya également des
techniques d'accompagnement psychosocial
avec des programmes qui ont importé du
québec qu'on développe actuellement en
france au titre de la fédération
addiction qui s'appelle alcochoix comme
son nom l'indiqué sont des dizaines à la
réduction des pensions
et on se rend compte que finalement
cette approche nous permet d'abord
d'avoir contact avec beaucoup plus de
personnes dans une ambiance réellement
d'année ans et thérapeutiques et non pas
de dressage peut être les sages
verticale avec ses limites et au final
ça permet d'avancer disait mais quel
moyen devrait être dédiée à la rdr
j'aurais tendance à dire que c'est là
une partie de l'avenue une partie de
l'avenir et qu'il faudrait aller
vraiment développé dans la pratique ce
qui était prévu dans la loi de santé de
2016 c'est à dire non seulement le
développement des salles de consommer
également le développement des
dispositifs d'un avis de produits ça
patauge un peu tous ces jeunes qui
puisent et des produits de synthèse mais
également développer
lagardère en prison pour autant la
réduction des risques ça suffit pas il
faut développer aussi donc deux fois mon
esprit au début il faut que les deux
soigner c'est à dire que c'est vraiment
absolument important ne pas enfermer non
plus uniquement les gens dans des
dispositifs coa zone et de réduction des
risques il faut que ça facilite leur
accès pour ceux qui le souhaitent à des
dispositifs sociaux d'hébergement
d'hébergement sans condition et les
usages sont tolérés ou on peut arriver
avec son chien on peut arriver en couple
comme on essaie de les développer
actuellement avec la famille mais
également des accès à un travail pour
les jeunes adapté avec des paiements la
journée comme comme tapage qui
actuellement se développe mais il faut
aussi avoir accès ou semble devoir le
classique avec une prison compte sip aux
logiques sociales manière intégrative et
y compris avec les soins des soins à duc
tho en examen sont ils suffisants non
recteur faudrait plus notamment parce
que là la diffusion générationnelle des
drogues et c'est aussi une diffusion
géographique
quand j'ai commencé il ya bien longtemps
en gros les drogues illégales c'est les
grandes métropoles
actuellement il ya une diffusion et
compris en milieu rural dans les villes
moyennes et autant le lacoste du kalka
de tabassage en quatre et on a un gros a
fait un gros effort à faire nous
rien pour arriver à diversifier nos
lieux d'intervention y compris à
l'occuper des gens au milieu semi-rural
alors peut-être que avec les
développements de la visio consultation
des téléconsultations il ya sans doute
une piste à suivre des facilités aux
sites et les prescriptions les
politiques d'aller vers a donc je crois
que là ya quelque chose à envisager
notamment aussi pour les consultations
jeunes consommateurs qui sont des lieux
absolument essentiel quant à 1 20 oui
les la problématique des usages addictif
s'est développée que la ram en chef chez
des femmes souvent en égaux avec des
mines et rabbit et psychologique à lui
plus important très stigmatisés enfin
des choses difficiles à porter et entre
en compte les facteurs déclenchants
s'ensuit barnier a à des éléments de
stress de violence de maltraitance de
passer individuel peut un peu compliqué
je pars de des patientes que nous voyons
dans nos centres sati présentent des
troubles les plus les plus sévères si
bien que pour ces personnes là il est
tout à fait important d'articuler des
actions de types a dicté au avec des
actions également de dead à l'estiment
de choix de la gestion des conflits au
traitement du psycho trop mal souvent se
rend compte qu'il ya des des antécédents
psychotraumatiques et donc développer
des systèmes d' aides spécifiques tels
que l'inde et on se rend compte que la
la demande des besoins sont absolument
majeur dès qu'on creuse un peu cette
question avec des sur les particularités
de genre dans le domaine des annexions
est clairement dans nos centres on a un
gros effort à faire de formation pour
que nous intervenons psychosociaux
d'ulysse mieux connaître ces techniques
d'intervention au plan national la
fédération addiction travaille
actuellement avec celle de m
au sens national résilience et l'éthique
au trône armonico pour qu'on arrive à
décliner les actions au niveau des
centres régionaux xive au traumatisme
qui sont dépendants ils gérés par des
établissements psychiatriques et on a
une action qu'il devrait être lancée
l'année prochaine en partenariat de
l'ancien deux élèves femme graça au
fonds national avec excusez moi j'ai été
très long mais il y avait énormément de
questions assure tente de les détailler
un petit peu merci
merci beaucoup pour vos réponses en
effet précisé et qui soulève plein de la
question complémentaire je suppose
laurence cohen bernard jomier et the
thing vitesse et annick jacques mais il
y aura encore un tiers
merci madame la présidente mais merci
docteur de l'île et monsieur orel
darrieux
effectivement vous avez apporté déjà
beaucoup de réponses
moi j'aimerais insister par rapport à
deux choses d'avoir la première chose ça
a été abordée sur la question du
cannabis j'ai été rapporteur longtemps
donc de la 1000 delta et à l'époque
j'avais travaillé sur la question des
addictions et j'avais réussi à faire en
sorte qu'il y ait une chape qu'ils
soient signés qui soit co élaborés avec
des professionnels des fédérations
d'addictologie c'était en 2012 et 1800
professionnels d'ailleurs avait signé
cette charte qui s'intitulait pour une
autre politique des addictions est le
dénominateur commun c'était on s'était
tous mis d'accord au moins sur la
dépénalisation de l'usagé du cannabis
bon même si on peut en voir aussi les
limites mais en réfléchissant en
analysant les choses et en voyant que ce
qui est pratiqué aujourd'hui en france
et bien non seulement n'apportent pas de
résultats
finalement probants et on voit bien dans
dans nos quartiers et quel que soit
quand j ai nos quartiers c'est vraiment
mais voilà les sénateurs et les
sénatrices sont très implantés
effectivement dans les collectivités et
on voit bien que il ya que tous les
trafics engendre des des violences qui
pourrissent littéralement le quotidien
des habitants et des habitants et que
donc il faudrait
arrêter cette politique plus basée sur
la répression je parle au niveau des
pouvoirs publics pas de ce que vous vous
faites en tant que professionnel bien
évidemment et donc il faudrait quand
même évolué et sa cheminée au minimum
vers cette dépénalisation j'aimerais
avoir aussi peut-être là-dessus
précisément de votre votre sentiment la
deuxième chose on n'en a pas parlé
c'est au sujet du but du crack parce
qu'on appelle on appelle ça plus
communément d'ailleurs la drogue du
pauvre ça a défrayé très récemment la en
début de semaine l'actualité avec la
situation la situation sur sur paris et
donc moi j'aimerais un petit peu avoir
votre avis parce que effectivement il y
à une expérimentation qui s'est fait en
belgique et qui est en fait la mise en
place d'une chambre en fait de
traitement qui est une chambre du
tribunal de première instance qui se
concentre non seulement sur les
infractions commises mais aussi sur les
soulage sur les problèmes qui sont
sous-jacents pardon et elle a été mise
de cette chambre de toxicomanie à à gand
en 2008 et je crois qu'elle permet
vraiment finalement au à la personne qui
appréhendent et de s'inscrire dans un
programme dead et si son parcours se
déroule bien le tribunal en fait peut en
tenir compte au moment où il va
effectivement bas faire tomber une une
sanction et je crois que et si je le pré
le prévenu donc on met vraiment la
personne au coeur du dispositif parce
que si cette personne donc ne répond pas
au programme des douze l'abandonnent
voilà à ce moment-là via le juge recours
à l'arsenal j'allais dire classique des
sanctions mais il ya sept
cette implication et de la personne qui
a été appréhendé et de la justice pour
essayer de travailler dans un
partenariat et pour aider la personne
à s'en sortir et en fait d'après les
chiffres que j'ai vu dans près de 70 %
des dossiers qui ont été introduites
devant la chambre de traitement est bien
ce programme dead a été mis mis en place
et il semblerait qu'il ya à peu près une
moitié disent eu d'issue favorable et
que ça diminue le risque de récidive
dans près de 80% des cas donc c'est
quand même assez intéressant donc que
pensez vous de cette proposition dont
qui est issu d'un pays voisins la
belgique est ce que vous pensez que ça
pourrait être une bonne une bonne
solution au niveau de la france et je
vous remercie par avance de vos réponses
merci père marmier merci madame la
présidente je vais m'en tenir à trois
questions la première porte sur l'alcool
on constate depuis plusieurs années un
ciblage sur les jeunes des des
fabricants d'alcool
d'ailleurs lé expertise récente
collective de l'inserm pointe également
cette cette question là quelques et
seraient vos réflexions à ce sujet et
vos propositions en termes de réponse
comment comment doit-on répondre à ce
ciblage ma deuxième question c'est
relativement cannabis alors bougez
évidemment je suis très intéressé par
les mouvements de l'opinion publique sur
cette question mais je pense qu'on doit
répondre à des questions de fond hockey
lors et on a besoin de votre vos
arguments de fond et d'autres expertises
une des questions à laquelle on doit
répondre c'est au fond jusqu où
l'interdiction est elle une bonne
prévention ou à partir de quand nettel
plus une prévention
voilà et on voit bien que quand
l'interdiction ne génère plus la rareté
l'indisponibilité d'un produit il ya un
argument qui qui s'estompe alors c'est
pas du tout la seule question à prendre
en compte mais là vous avez certainement
à des éléments à nous apporter y compris
sur les expériences d'autres pays qui
quand ils ont champ
j'ai deux paradigmes at-on assisté
agneaux à dos at on assiste à une aux
dans telle ou telle catégorie de
population chez les plus jeunes chez les
moins jeunes as t'on assisté à une
hausse avec profil de consommation
massive qui pose problème ou de
consommation très sporadique et
intermittente qui ne pensent pas
nécessairement de preuve voilà sage jeu
ça m'intéresserait beaucoup de vous
entendre sa question
quelques modules de delhaize ces mères
et parce que le sait revenu dans
l'actualité
donc moi j'étais adjoint à paris quand
on a ouvert la première salle est
d'ailleurs les riverains
juste une parenthèse pardon dans ma
question mais les sondages sur les
riverains ont une signification très
aléatoire on peut prendre les chiffres
très favorables les moins favorables
la réalité c'est que si quelqu'un qui
vit dans un endroit où il n'y a pas
d'usagers de drogues vous lui dites on
va implanter une salle de consommation
ont bâti ou êtes d'accord
il va sans doute vous dire qu'il n'a pas
trop envie là où on a ouvert la salle à
paris c'est pas n'importe où les gens
ils avaient sur le trottoir devant chez
eux tous les matins des seringues
il emmenait les gamins à l'école il y
avait des cinq qui traînaient les
usagers de drogues étaient dans la rue
et la salle a fait rentrer une grande
partie de ses usagers de drogues dans la
salle et non plus dans la rue et donc
après il ya des positions idéologiques
qui font que on mettra jamais tout le
monde d'accord mais après on évaluer
objectivement il est des comptes qui a
été fait on a une grande expérience
puisque à une centaine de salles dans le
monde pour prendre ce seul critère en
général c'est en six mois 70 à 80% de
seringues en moins a ramassé par terre
dans la rue voilà donc évidemment la
parole des riverains est importante
notamment quand ils font installer un
dispositif de ce type il faut les
consulter il faut les mettre dans la
concertation mais les enquêtes d'opinion
au général sur cette question bon voilà
je ferme la parenthèse mais le débat est
ressorti la à propos de la situation à
stalingrad j'ai lu du 19e par ayant
arrêté je ne suis plus des municipales
mais certes c'est une partie de la
réponse
mais il ya quand même un grand problème
les usagers trac on est au bout de la
problématique de santé mentale et de
psychiatrie quand même c'est ce sont des
personnes qui sont qui ont besoin de
soins en la matière et de soins enfin
d'âcre auch ii bat seul
enfin on n'emploie plus vraiment
l'expression au début mais de les amener
vers des dispositifs essais et c'est
compliqué et là on est en carence de
dispositifs une carence qui est tout de
même criante et une absence de réponse
qui est un peu désespérante
le chef de l'état annonçait des assises
de la santé mentale et de la psychiatrie
qui doivent se tenir avant la fin du
mois de juin je ne sais pas si vous avez
la date
moi j'arrive toujours pas à la trouver
long et 8 juin je crois que monsieur de
lille est un des signataires avec tout
un certain nombre d'organisations d'une
lettre ouverte parce que la fédération
qui préside je crois n'est même pas
associée à ces assises de la santé
mentale et de la psychiatrie mais
comment peut-on pas j'ai pas assez peu
entendu parler au fond de cette question
mais sur la question des addictions
on est quand même là au coeur de la
problématique et on est en carence de
dispositifs qui est massive donc est ce
que par hasard vous en seriez plus sur
ces assises de la santé mentale et de la
psychiatrie et sur les débouchés
possibles
merci justin bieber merci madame la
présidente
on a parlé pas mal traitement de
substitution et à ce titre ce que la
cigarette et tonique
est-ce qu'on peut la considérer comme un
traitement qui permet une réduction de
la consommation de tabac aux côtés des
substituts nicotiniques sachant que
certains qui ne fumaient pas se mettent
à consommer ce genre de produit pensant
que ce n'est pas dangereux
merci on pourrait y ajouter le tabac
chauffer
granic jacques mais oui merci présidente
pour monsieur alors un certain nombre de
réponses ont déjà été données aux
questions que j'avais à apposer
notamment sur les alcoolisme ou les
stupéfiants par rapport aux cures de
désintoxication par contre je crois pas
avoir entendu
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire à moyen
et long terme quel est le pourcentage de
guérison ou de rechute le docteur de
lille a parlé de la prise en charge
après à et du suivi mais est-ce que vous
avez des pourcentages de rechute par
rapport à ces à ses addictions la
concernant les jeux vidéo dont vous avez
parlé
monsieur morel pour les enfants à partir
de quel âge ou en dessous de quel âge
c'est complètement complètement
déconseillée pour les conséquences qui
pourraient y avoir et la troisième chose
qui m'interpelle c'est qu'on parle
maintenant depuis je ne sais pas combien
de temps d'ailleurs 0 verre d'alcool et
zéro cigarette pour les femmes enceintes
or quand j'ai eu mes enfants il ya
trente ans où nous mêmes sommes nés de
parents qui n'avaient pas que ces
consignes là et à ce que je vois on
n'est pas trop mal réussi
alors pourquoi ce revirement est ce que
les substances ont changé et ce qu'on
ouvre des parapluies est ce que la
recherche a donné des résultats
on ne connaissait sûrement pas j'allais
dire à notre époque mais quelque part ça
m'interpelle un petit peu que le
balancier partent aussi loin dans
l'autre sens
alors est ce que vous avez est-ce que
vous avez une explication par rapport à
cette nouvelle façon de gérer la
grossesse des femmes
merci frédérique puissat ensuite un à
milan et chantal de seine
oui mercian à la présidente alors je
vais être assis rapide de temps que ma
question n'est pas une question mais
plutôt une demande à vous madame la
présidente je voulais revenir sur les
salles de consommation alors je parle
avec beaucoup de prudence d'abord parce
que j'en ai visité aucune et je suis en
plus que la commission sociale moment
l'expérimentation avait plutôt émis
un regard plutôt bienveillant sur 7 sur
ladite expérimentation néanmoins
dernière jonnier a affirmé la parenthèse
de l'entourage de l'implantation de ces
salles de consommation je voudrais
ouvrir cette parenthèse on regarde
notamment d'un article que j'ai lu ce
matin dans le figaro je dis pas que le
figaro et est l'alpha et l'oméga de la
vérité encore que mais je vous invite à
relire je dois l'écrire le dire parce
que alors on parle pas de paris 1
on parle plutôt de strasbourg et quand
on lit effectivement le témoignage des
habitants qui sont proximité de cette
salle de consommation
j'avoue que ça fait froid dans le dos et
qu'on a un peu le sentiment qu'on a
sacrifié la vie sociale d'une partie de
nos populations
un enjeu de bénéfices santé un enjeu de
bénéfice coût donc je sais pas d'âme la
présidence si nous aurons l'occasion
en amont de ce qu'annonce le
gouvernement puisqu'il souhaite
effectivement donné suite leur apporte
des fermes et pérenniser le dispositif
je sais pas si nous aurons l'occasion
d'en reparler mais j'imagine bien que
les membres de la commission sociale
notamment issus du milieu médical auront
un avis mais je pense que les élus de
territoire que nous sommes doivent aussi
un moment donné à voir un avis sur
effectivement ce type d'implantation qui
peut quand même posé un certain nombre
de difficultés et avec parfois des
décisions nationales qui tout d'un coup
ça rime à des réalités locales qui
peuvent parfois créer des facs des
fractures qu'on connaît trop c'est moi
qui réponds demande entendue à la nuit
long oui merci
j'ai d'abord je voudrais dire quand même
à faire et puis ça que nous avions à
l'époque voter les salles de
consommation ici au sénat c'est une
proposition qui avait été faite par le
rapporteur que j'étais et que sa mère
ait valu me faire traiter de docteurs
m'ont guérie par les élus du front
national du du vaucluse
mais je reviens donc maintenant à tout
ce qui a été dit par part vous de
messieurs et vous remercier de l'énorme
énergie que vous dépensez pour lutter
contre certains types de drogues comme
toutes les addictions mais contre
certains types de drogues avec un succès
qui est malheureusement extrêmement
minime
je voudrais revenir sur ce que dit le
ministre d'intérieur il dit
régulièrement que le marché parallèle
des drogues illicites ces quelques
milliards d'euros de dépenses par an que
ces cinq milliards là l'économie
française n'en voit pas la couleur
est ce que vous avez fait vous une étude
sur la possible suppression de la
monnaie ou d'argent liquide afin
d'éliminer ces marchés parallèles
pour compléter ce cas d un ami l'ont en
effet lors de la loi touraine on avait
néanmoins été favorable à aux salles de
shoot à l'époque à condition qu'elles
soient à dos et un établissement
hospitalier de façon à ce qu'il y ait ce
passage près du pré du soin
je pense pas que ce soit le cas partout
oui à paris mais pas forcément pour
pourra être à la fois d'un axe en effet
de prévention rapport aux patients aux
toxicomanes mais aussi de rentrer dans
une démarche de soins et pour terminer
chantal de seine si madame la présidente
et messieurs avez vous une visibilité
sur l'ouverture sur la programmation
d'ouverture de salles de consommation à
moindre risque
alors que l'expérimentation menée à
paris et à strasbourg est plutôt
positive il y a quelques années on
parlait d' ouverture de salles sur
marseille et sur bordeaux où en sont ses
projets merci à 95 à une question
apparemment savoir qu'il n'avait pas
vraiment la main avec une amie sur le
tchat
bonjour bonjour à tous les je pense que
vous avez en partie répondu aux
questions par rapport à la situation par
part est parti ma collègue a posé la
question par rapport à notre situation
d'il ya 30 ans 35 en mai par rapport aux
je voudrais savoir s'il ya eu des études
réels qui ont été faites sur les enfants
de moins de 3 ans puisque maintenant
c'est interdiction de regarder le
moindre écran avant trois ans je dois
dire que quand mes filles étaient
petites gens mettaient une devant la
télévision pendant je préparais l'autre
pour aller à l'école et que maintenant
les l'une ni l'autre ne regardent plus
la télévision
donc je ne ne sais pas si c'est des cas
exceptionnels mais surtout je vois mes
enfants me dire ah non non on peut plus
regarder des informations on peut plus
rien faire parce qu'il faut absolument
pas le cas
un écran avant trois ans d'où provient
ces éléments et est-ce que effectivement
ça provoque des addictions
merci beaucoup de questions alors qu'ils
commencent
vous allez monsieur morel d'arleux
pensez que votre ancien maire de lille
termine juste préciser je me tiens à
disposition de la commission pour
répondre aux questions auxquelles je
n'aurais pas répondu ou pour fournir
tous les éléments il ya via
l'administration du sénat
tous les éléments la commission des
études qui ont été faites il ya beaucoup
de réactions puisque d'ailleurs de
questions on voit effectivement que 1
des débats autour de votre position
autour des salles de consommation salles
de consommation à moindre risque et je
vous invite aussi votre commission a
entendu notre belle équipe de l'inserm
tient qu'à mener ce travail est très
récent et dont les travaux étaient
rendus deux autres très récemment à sait
que la mission interministérielle de
lutte contre les drogues et les
conduites addictives
juste pour vous dire je pense deux
éléments de contexte c'est à dire que le
travail d'implémentation de ses salles
elles répondent à l'étranger comme en
france à une amende une implémentation
dans des lieux où il ya des usages
préalable de consommation problématiques
dire qu on ne va pas planter c'est sa
viande et des espaces uni veut pas trop
sommation mais bien ça vient répondre à
un endroit où les usages et or sont déjà
présents et les décisions d'orientation
se sont songeurs en fait après un
échange long avec les pouvoirs locaux et
les collectivités territoriales les
acteurs de terrain
la préfecture et les services de l'état
donc on a effectivement on entend comme
moi j'ai pas d'éléments concrets sur la
l'ouverture peut-être jean-michel de
lille à bordeaux m à bordeaux et à
marseille à lille qui sont les villes
dont on régulièrement parler on sait
qu'il ya des collectifs d'associations
et de soutien qui sont mobilisés pour
repousser l'ouverture là néanmoins on
voit qu'on est encore en france dans des
débats autour de l'acceptabilité de ces
salles là où on le montre lorsque c'est
effectivement on est face à des lieux où
il ya des usages réguliers et
potentiellement problématique d'après
lui la tranquillité publique et des
conséquences sanitaires de drogue dans
l'espace public qu'elles ont un effet
positif de réduction des risques et donc
je pense à un élément à garder en tête
et je ferai le lien sur cette question
là avec effectivement les usages de
crack on a de tout cas une base et on a
travaillé avec l'inserm à une partie de
l'équipe des gars qui a fait
l'évaluation sur les salles de
consommation à moindre risque sur les
situations et on a rendu donc une
synthèse de nos rapports en début
d'année sur l'assuré situation c 3e dan
et delà du crack en ile-de-france une
situation qui s'est alors qu'il eut
énormément de moyens qui ont été mis
pour de l'accompagnement médico sociales
d'accompagnement en terme d'hébergement
pour effectivement sortir les usagers de
la rue et d'une consommation dans
l'espace public on voit bien que la une
année de crise sanitaire est venu aussi
impacté le travail qui est fait par les
profanes et le terrain et services de
l'état au plan local avec l'appui
effectivement c'est quand même le plan
crack qui était porté par la ville de
paris les récifs de france la préfecture
d'île de france
la musique arabe et appelant qu'il
mobilise l'ensemble des acteurs à la
friture de police néanmoins on voit bien
que là on est dans une situation qui est
une situation un peu au petit smic
ces derniers ces dernières semaines mais
ce qui va ce qui fonctionne et ce qui
pose le principe est simple que soulever
dans le chef de l'état
comment on fait le lien entre la
réduction des risques et l'accès à
d'autres niveaux de soins avec aussi
pour les usagers de crack l'accès à des
des espaces où ils sont finalement des
espaces de repos des espaces
d'hébergement éloigné des espaces de
consommation et des espaces à des points
qu'ils avaient été sortis de l'enquète
sur les trajectoires auprès des
professionnels et des usagers du crack
le blème menée par l'inserm 2 tu peux la
fête en commun c'est effectivement pas
finalement changé aussi de regard c'est
à dire qu'il me demande d'hébergement
individualisé n'a pas de ses usagers
alors qu'on avait une représentation
collective souvent de dire c'est des
consommations qui sont collectives
et même dans la partie inhalation de
l'astag de conservation à moindre risque
de paris était une des cabines des
nations collective alors en fait
finalement il ya aussi un besoin de
consommation de régulation de la
consommation de manière individuelle ça
c'est des mois je vous invite à
interroger l'équipe de l'inserm qui a
travaillé sur ce sujet très rapidement à
ce que je ne vais pas en minutes et 45
secondes devraient apporter des réponses
sur la question de la légalisation du
cannabis et sur les peurs par exemple on
a au niveau international on vous invite
je vous renverrai les liens aux rapports
franco munitions les expériences qu'ils
existent outre atlantique on est avec le
soutien du fonds de lutte prédictions
sur un programme qui s'appelle
l'astrakan et qui compare et finalement
ce qui est ce qui a été réalisé dans
trois états des vrais que enfin des
états unis et trois provinces
canadiennes avec deux approches
différentes approches par état très
diversifié avec une des lois qui ne sont
pas comparables d'état en état sur la
légalisation du cannabis 10 récréatif et
une loi fédérale au canada depuis 2018
mais qui est déclinée aussi manière très
différente selon les provinces
canadiennes ce qui est des états
fédéraux ce conte l'élément principal
qui va retenir c'est qu'effectivement il
faut bien avoir bien être au clair sur
l' attente initiale de labellisation de
sa mise en oeuvre pour pouvoir mesurer
ses effets ça paraît être un peu une
lapalissade de le dire mais c'est on
aura pas de changements qu'on n'a pas
attendu qu'on n'a pas souhaité au départ
ce qui est caractéristique de ces deux
de ces différentes juridictions
atlantique c'est que il ya un contrôle
strict de l'interdiction de vente aux
mineurs et qui effectivement depuis la
légalisation il n'y a pas eu
d'augmentation des consommations chez
les mineurs puisqu'on est dans des pays
où la tradition du contrôle de
l'interdiction de vente aux mineurs est
aussi respecté quelles que soient la
caisse dans tous les états concernés il
ya une augmentation des consommations si
les adultes mais à partir du moment où
vous légaliser un usage et ghoul rendait
possible la communication la publicité
de même la faim et la diversification
des produits vous avez effectivement des
gens qui vont aller l'expérimenté qui
m'ont pour partie qu'on en consomme et
alors qu'il n'en consommait pas
préalablement et on n'est pas là dans
des biais de déclarations avant le
disait pas parce que c'était interdit on
le dit maintenant que c'est très bien
qu'il ya une diffusion du produit qu'il
se fait puisque il est il est illégal et
donc tout l'enjeu et c'est là une vraie
diversité voix je vous renvoie
effectivement travaux qu'on a fait parce
que entre entre les différents états on
voit soyez des états otis ans dans les
logiques de son débit très forte avec un
contrôle très strict de la mise à
disposition des produits de contrôle
qualité des produits la capacité de
distribuer ce produit entre le
producteur et le magasin de détail où
les hausses seront plutôt contrôlé et
les des effets non désirés sont plutôt
restreint et puis d'autres états je vais
citer le colorado qui est le plus connu
nous on a effectivement une approche
très libérale très marché orienté comme
on dit de du cannabis et on va trouver
effectivement toutes sortes de produits
cosmétiques comestibles et des bruits
très fortement dosée en cannabis à
inhaler ou ou à fumer ou là on a vu des
effets dès le départ sur des impacts sur
les actions de la route par exemple ou
sur les urgences médicales
faut vraiment mesuré donc on travaille
en aura on a des rapports intermédiaires
qui ont été mis en ligne à l'année
dernière
on aura un deuxième volet d' sur cette
enquête qur en 2022 et puis autre
élément important mais on va aussi
publié début juillet à l'occasion des 20
ans de la loi portugaise sûr
que la dépénalisation des usages de
stupéfiant et donc l'orientation vers
des commissions effectivement médico
social des usagers de deux produits donc
enfin bilan un peu détaillé de cette loi
qui sera en ligne sur notre site et qui
donc les études vous évaluer le passage
à des drogues plus dures qui est souvent
un peu un des obstacles et donner ainsi
à la légalisation en disant ça va
augmenter le passage à des drogues plus
dures
un report du trafic si je puis dire
alors on le fait dans les années 70 on a
évoqué cette question de l'hôtel la
théorie de l'escaladé qui a largement
été démentie par les travaux en fait il
n'y a pas de lien de causalité entre le
fait d'avoir consommé un jour du tabac
ou d'alcool ou ou du cannabis et après
de consommer d'autres d'autres
substances on a des niveaux de diffusion
des produits qui sont pas les mêmes et
donc on retrouve effectivement chez des
usagers d'héroïne cocaïne des gens qui
avait consommé d'autres produits avant
mais en fait l'élément principal et je
pense que jean-michel de le prévoir dans
la maison de prévention et de ces
dernières années ça renvoie une des
captures questions ont été posées sur la
règle et 3 6 9 12 donc les sur la
prévention des écrans donc les règles de
santé publique de prévenir au maximum en
fait l'accès et de retarder finalement
l'âge d'entrée dans des consommations
d'eau ou dans les usages donc les 3 3 en
6 ans 9 ans 12 ans pour les pour les
écrans donc nous en les réseaux sociaux
9 je dirais des jeux vidéo si la
télévision et 3 pas d'écran avant un jeu
de mémoire je ne suis pas spécialiste de
santé publique
mais je vous renvoie sur six écrans
entre alors ce sont ces c'est surtout
d'avoir des réflexes et des messages de
santé publique les plus clair possible
il s'adonne ça donne des caps ça veut
pas dire que un enfant qui regarde la
télévision avant trois ans deviendra
consommateurs d'héroïne quand il sera
grand
on a quand même dépassé c'est c'est
logique là donc vraiment une logique de
prévention est un des éléments qui
étaient quand même important et je le
prends parce que ça fait partie des
éléments d'effet positif de
de boutiques santé publique par exemple
en vingt ans on a reculé de 15 mois
l'âge de d'initiation à la cigarette
chez nos adolescents en france ont
établi un effet on est passé de 13 ans à
14 ans et demi voilà donc c'est bien un
effet de deux de ses usages de
prévention et on sait que plus on
commence tard les usages moins il y à
des risques d' usage problématique
oui de mener dans lapidaire il y avait
une question qui nous faisait sur
n'était pas un peu déprimé par le côté
ray lui finalement de notre résultat et
du coup je rebondis sur ce que vient de
dire julien du point de vue d'aider des
soignants comme je suis non on n'est pas
déprimé parce que figurez vous qu'il ya
énormément de gens que nous et donc ils
vont mieux et puis c'est à dire
l'évolution généralement est favorable
mais elle est longue
ça prend des années en revanche la
difficulté à laquelle on est confronté
c'est que plus il y en a qui sortent
plus il y en a qui en connaît dans un
flot permanent
parfois c'est le lot de la médecine en
espère rapidement arriver erratique et
complètement une problématique mais
finalement dans le domaine des
addictions saada poté - un peu moins
désespérant que par rapport à certains
troubles psychiatriques caractérisée on
sent que là il ya un poids de la
publicité qui est vraiment là l'autre
élément de satisfaction c'est qu'on se
rend compte que les actions de
prévention ne dit pas assez mais c'était
dit à l'instant commence à rapporter
leurs fruits notamment chez les jeunes
le retard de l'expérimentation des
produits la diminution à prévalence
tabagique chez les jeunes la diminution
de la prévalence des épaules également
en fin d'expérimentation
la diminution de d'un certain nombre
d'indicateurs de septembre annonce ce
qui va se produire petit à petit donc il
y avait réellement de dévolution maisons
corses ont pas fait valoir alors pour
les appuyer là je répondrais de manière
lapidaire à traiter toutes les questions
remarquable que vous avez posé la
dépénalisation évidemment n'est
favorable défavorable quasiment depuis
depuis toujours aux comptes les drogues
c'est à dire on pense pas que le en
faire un délit pénal soit quelque chose
qui soit une quelconque efficacité puis
au contraire ça peut faire courir des
risques supplémentaires en termes de de
stigmatisation de misaine et 4 donc sans
doute faut-il arriver avec deux montées
à interdire certaines choses sans une
panne semble type du ressort d'un délit
d'un délit pénal
l'une des critiques que nous avions
faite à la prise de position du ministre
l'intérieur concernant la lutte contre
les trafics ce qu'évidemment il faut
lutter contre les trafics qu'entre ces
phénomènes de violences qui se sont
multipliées dans certaines villes
compris des villes moyennes par
proximité des grandes villes mais en ne
se concentrant pas uniquement sur une
réponse répressive et policière il est
évident que pour arriver à réduire ces
mécanismes là il faut avoir une
articulation des actions de prévention
de soins et une politique qui soit
global n'ont pas toujours l'illusion de
pouvoir éradiquer des phénomènes sociaux
comportementaux uniquement par une
réponse policière
la question sur craquer santé mentale on
est au coeur du problème c'est à dire le
plan trac était un plan global pour des
les autres qui ont été évoquées il n'a
pas été réellement mises en oeuvre mais
les usagers de crack sont des usages est
extrêmement marginaux vous plongeront
désinsérer aux parts sociales et chez
lesquels il ya une prévalence de
troubles mentaux caractérisés pour le
port extrêmement importante
ce qui veut dire que de toute évidence
c'est leur emblème même de ce qui
devrait appeler les politiques globales
a été intégré à la fois social médical
psychiatrique et anne itto logique mais
qui passe également par de l'action
sociale de l'hébergement du travail
c'est à dire c'est que je salue le fait
que les vestales pu être associé à des
puces hôpitaux comme adossés à des
hôpitaux comme à paris les à strasbourg
ça pourrait être utile en cas d'overdose
eu d'incident aygulf en revanche là où
il faut qu'elle soit vraiment été lavé
les services sociaux addictif et de
santé mentale
et là il d'un effort vous connaissez la
difficulté actuellement des collègues
qui sont actuellement à l'hôpital dans
la psychiatrie au public
on essaye de développer effectivement
des équipes mobiles psychiatrie
précarité il faut arriver à les intégrer
avec vos propres dispositifs et vert
donc pour voir il va faire de
décloisonnement mais avec des structures
et des qui n'ont pas réellement
l'habitude de travailler ensemble
quelles que soient les volontés des
acteurs de terrain donc on attend
effectivement notre chance politique
qu'elle ne se limite pas à une illusoire
réponse est physiquement impossible mais
qu'elle pousse les ars les directions de
la cohésion sociale a réellement
décloisonner la pratique de toute façon
ils suscitent ils soutiennent la mise en
place de l'équipe intégrée
c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire
actuellement peut-être dans l'est dans
la suite du seigneur de la santé et la
mesure votre site mais également le
l'i-miev est ce sens de l'aide de la
diact alors sur les chambres de
traitement cité l'exemple belge
c'est un exemple à fait intéressant qui
rappelle un peu celui des drogues cordes
et aux drogues qu'on voit aux états unis
qu'on a également fait un travail là
dessus en partenariat avec des
partenaires de la justice c'est un petit
sentier justice du coup vous vous
adresserez et deux pour notre part en
sont tout à fait favorables à la mise en
place de dispositifs adaptés pourquoi
parce qu'on se rend compte que quand on
demande à des gens qu'il y avait un
problème de dépendance qui les a poussés
finalement à avancer vers une résolution
de ce problème on se rend compte que ce
qui sort comme motif explicatif c'est le
sentiment de responsabilité par rapport
à ses proches à ses enfants quand ils
grandissent par rapport à sa femme son
mari et ses més évolué si finalement le
fait qu'ils étaient confrontés à un
rappel d'interdît côté justice donc le
tout est de faire en sorte que ce rappel
soit bénéfique et non pas que le remède
soit pire que le mal souci permanent en
médecine qui devrait l'être aussi dans
l'appareil judiciaire bernard jomier
évoqué la question du sida
je crois que vraiment là aussi il faut
s'inspirer vient avec les états unis sur
l'application rigoureuse
aux etats unis les doigts des sciences
va pas plus là ça revienne la loi avec
nous c'est à dire si vous essayez
d'entrer dans sa victoire sport que vous
avez un look un peu ado essaie d'avoir
le whisky ça marche pas par ici même
vous envoyer directe de la politique il
ya des rennais en france mais elles sont
moyennement appliquée donc il faudrait
le faire mais surtout le mode de
consommation des jeunes évolue c'est à
dire la consommation quotidienne de nos
grands parents de ma génération de bain
dams est en voie d'extinction clairement
ce qui se passe actuellement chez les
jeunes c'est plus un mode anglo saxons
de recherche d'ivresse donc empoché une
recherche des faits psychotropes
ce qui veut dire que les la question -
celle d'une pression sociétale qui
poussait tout le monde à part a
finalement de l'alcool mais plus une
pression juvénile renforcée par la
publicité
quand moment qu'ils sont ce qu'on voyait
est classiquement dans les pays anglo
saxons donc quand ça renvoie des mines
est habilité il faut développer des
fonctions un autre c'est à dire
compléter les actions grand public qui
ont lieu par des actions beaucoup plus
ciblée sur les jeunes promouvoir et
développer les consultations jeunes
consommateurs de telle façon qu'elle
puisse recevoir les personnes des jeunes
qui font des ivresses répétées et faire
une évaluation psychologique et sociale
qui soit accompagné développer les
campagnes de prévention on avait fait
qu'il soit ciblée sur les jeunes avec
des plus ludiques style grunge anneaux
harry qui soit orientée abstinence aucun
sens mais plutôt lisse des consommations
extérieur de nos régions et c'est donc
la mona lisa de ce côté là qu il faut qu
il faut avancer
en dix ans la question était
passionnante où l'interdiction d'être
préventive je crois qu'elle peut être
préventive dans un monde qui renie tout
principe d'autorité quand elle est
fondée sur des éléments rationnels et
pragmatiques dans la mesure où on sait
que des villages de cannabis par exemple
chez des jeunes notamment où avant 15
ans pour avoir des effets délétères sur
le fonctionnement cognitif sur le risque
de développer un trouble psychotique
il est logique que la communauté des
fans sans barde s'est donnée pour
justifier
maintien d'un interdit appliquer deux
visages même façon c'est compréhensible
par rapport au volant par rapport au
travail par rapport à des métiers
d'expositions etc
donc je crois qu'il fait pas trop tôt
cela que ça peut être intéressant
les expériences américaines il ya un
excellent travail de 2 mdt
je suis je suis d'accord ça durant les
suit de très près en gros quand les
enjeux économiques l'ont emporté
c'est à dire quand on dérégule
complètement qu'on tolère des donneurs
de thc très élevée quand on a une
politique de prix bas on taxait pas vos
goûts on a un impact économique berne
auteur de contre attaque le contrarier
fortement le marché noir qui s'adapte
qui a des capacités résidence important
mais on va avoir un impact économique
important
en revanche en santé publique on a des
mauvais résultats il ya une augmentation
sur 10 des passages aux urgences
accident la circulation de
l'augmentation
chez les adultes alors ça ne bouge pas
chez les jeunes on dit toujours mais
regardez c'est passé dangereux le point
qu'il faut c'est chez les jeunes c'est
toujours interdit aux états unis et ça
n'interdit appliquée quelles que soient
les ai pas même si j'ai gagné alors
qu'en france
paradoxal ans donc presque ne pas
appliquer alors que c'est que ses
intérêts en revanche ce n'est les états
qui ont des dix états de l'est notamment
des états unis qui ont été plus
sensibles à des enjeux de santé publique
et qui donc ont été beaucoup plus
prudent système de contrôle de
régulation d'accession et de get down
impact plus faible en terme de recettes
si j'ose dire économique
jusque là pour le coup le marché noir
est reste efficace sur l'aspect la
question précise apportée par le krach
sur santé mentale précarité addiction ce
qu'on a dit au ministre mars
est-ce que nous sommes invités aux
assises non est-ce qu'on a des infos sur
les assises non alors effectivement avec
des camarades notamment de l'unafam des
familles le personnel concerné et donner
parce que c'est évidemment une question
clé est au nous redoutons en quelque
sorte qu'elle soit réservée uniquement à
la psychiatrie publique ce qui est
encore une fois j'ai longtemps travaillé
aux petits gâteries que je respecte
totalement leur jeu mais la santé
mentale des bords de la romanche nasa
doit intégrer
dimension sociale médico-sociale et
notamment à victo il faut évidemment
pour soient intégrés donc je n'ai aucune
information le premier qui a une
information très bien très bien à
l'autre lorsque les questions sur les
écrans oui car hier à trois ans c'est
pas tellement par rapport au risque
addictif
c'est par rapport au risque d'altération
comme ultime est là pour le coup il ya
vraiment des études assez robuste qui
sont bien demande en cédant dans le
directeur de recherche liens que tout le
monde connaît des murs et on regarde le
thème le polémique mais les sources des
sources qui donne sont extrêmement
robuste sur la dangerosité cognitives
des des écrans et les moins de trois
heures qui leur est effectivement la
télé ça s'est un peu différente jeu
vidéo
je n'entre pas dans le détail si j'ose
dire
les prochaines ouvertures de smr j'ai
pas beaucoup d'informations il semble
effectivement que lille marseille lille
et strasbourg soit envisagé en cas il ya
des fonds qui ont été vidés dans
diverses choses vont avancer notamment
notamment évidemment dans ma vie e sur
le parallèle qui était fait entre
traitement de substitution cigarette
électronique
je m'excuse c'est tout ça c'est la
misère mais bon c'est la règle du jeu
les cigarettes électroniques de mon
point de vue elle son remarquable qu'ont
termes d'outils de réduction des risques
là à mon avis a pas de débat c'est à
dire chez quelqu'un qui a un fumeur de
tabac le fait de passer la cigarette
électronique est de toute façon un
bienfait pour ses poumons et ça en soit
c'est bon deuxième temps il ya plusieurs
études maintenant qu'ils montrent que ça
peut être effectivement une aide au
chauffage chez des gens qui fument du
tabac sait on le voit en pratique c'est
quand même quelque chose qui va
faciliter de sevrage le roman - moins
difficile il ya vraiment une dimension
d'articulation réduction des risques et
soins ce que je vous dis depuis le début
c'est à dire on part avec une demande de
l'usager donc été simple réduction des
risques et on se rend compte que parmi
ces visages est un certain nombre vont
vouloir aller plus loin et à ce moment
là il faut leur proposer du complément
avec des patchs on peut associer les
deux 20 des modalités et il ya beaucoup
d'études hors contrôle et qui montre
c'est un dispositif efficace revanche je
suis d'accord avec le bémol c'est pour
aïcha en bois un peu ce qu'on disait sur
le cannabis auparavant pour une des
jeunes on le voit aux états unis bleus
tabac fumé pratiquement chez les jeunes
en revanche qui s'est développé ces la
vaporisation cigarettes alors de tabac
et le cannabis et ont clairement ça peut
être le mode d'entrée donc autant pour
des fumeurs que ça soit en termes de
réduction des risques et de soins ça me
semble de toute la soirée bénéfice
autant il faut être vigilant sur la
possibilité d'être un mode d'entrée dans
la nicotine ou les usages de cannabis
chez chez des jeunes est sans doute
faut-il des tribulations comparables sur
les femmes les femmes enceintes alors le
danger avec le tabac a été opéré
récemment c'est un vrai danger toute
façon il ya un sur-risque de petit
périmètre crânien et un sur risque de
naissance prématurée qui elle-même son
insu risque pour la suite de problèmes
développementaux et il peut y avoir des
problèmes d'intoxication et hull oxyde
de carbone avec parfois des incidents
chez chez les bébés donc le tabac et
aucun ordre par rapport à l'alcool
je suis comme black comme vous je suis
bordelais je pense que sinon mes parents
du mois mais quand par an on a un grand
mère n'arrêtait pas arrêté de consommer
un peu de vin pendant la grossesse
nous n'avons pas tous le sentiment
d'être totalement à intéresser des
données statistiques qui montrent des
études qui ont permis de repérer quand
même la dangerosité de la consommation
d'alcool
or là on est entre nous est la
représentation publique je dois être
l'autre direct il n'y a pas d'études qui
montrent peu 0 c'est un objectif
nécessaire d'exception vert pendant les
neuf mois de grossesse un verre de
champagne
il est vraisemblable qu'il va pas y
avoir un effet dramatique c'est ce qu'on
appelle les prolongements courbe
c'est à dire par extrapolation supposer
que l'idéal c'est zéro et surtout ce qui
était apparu utile la santé publique
française roux d'acteur c'est que c'est
un message qui était plus facile à
comprendre et faire comprendre et à
partager
puisqu'on a pas réellement de seuils ou
peu facile de précaution effectivement
qui amène ya mène 1 à 0
là je pense qu en argent liquide c'est
sans doute une bonne piste en tout cas
pour les gros billets et dans le domaine
une lutte contre les trafics a
simplement dans le domaine de droit mais
vous comprenez place evènement mon
domaine et expertises d'agf aurait fait
appel à d'autres
d'autres intervenants voilà je crois
qu'il fait un peu le tour a brièvement
mais vous avez évoqué la cigarette
électronique tabac chauffer vous avez un
recul vous sur le tabac chauffer qui
nous avait été présenté sur lequel est
d'ailleurs ministère la santé a jamais
donné vraiment de davie spécialement
favorable puisque l'unc a dénoncé le
tapage nocturne avec globalement la
doctrine actuellement serait de laisser
dans la dans le chapitre tabac en
général puisque il ya effectivement
moins de riches peut-être s'en nourrit
au plan plan pulmonaire
en revanche les risques d'accrochage
sont tout aussi aussi importants puisque
cardiovasculaires sont également
importants ce qui fait que de deux
points du las le consensus actuel qui
peut évoluer en fonction de lait des
données c'est de là didier sur ma
connaissance il ya des différences et
d'abbas n'y fait omv
certains jurés doivent vraiment là on
entre vraiment dans la technique est
pour le moment on n'a pas vraiment gros
développement de ce type de pratiques
l'actualité c'est vraiment des cigales
écoutez merci beaucoup pour ces échanges
très intéressants à tous les deux merci
monsieur morel d'arleux compléter
éventuellement si vous avez des éléments
on essaiera peut-être dans tant de
l'inserm en effet par rapport aux seules
consommations de qui nous présentent
leurs études
un rapport de 600 pages ils vont avoir
des choses à nous dire
donc merci beaucoup merci avoisine
micouleau d'avoir initié cette rencontre
et merci à chaque sens de la voit elle
aussi organisé initiés donc merci
beaucoup
[Musique]